[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: At Google
data centers, we
have a relentless
focus on performance.
Our data centers are
more than just buildings
with a collection of
machines wired together.
They host clusters of
hundreds of thousands
of servers in locations
across the globe
that need to act as
a unified network.
So what does it take to
operate and build them
efficiently at massive scale?
It all comes down to
four core principles--
performance, availability,
security, and sustainability.
To optimize for
performance, we don't rely
on off-the-shelf components.
We customize the
design and build
of almost every
part of the stack
for ultra high performance.
This includes electrical
substations, servers, racks,
and even how we
operate cooling plants.
You might think that means
we're using high-end computers.
But at Google, we build
from the bottom up.
Commodity hardware
underpins our custom tech
stack that runs
hundreds of thousands
of jobs across these machines
to give you distributed
performance and scale.
But this doesn't mean we're
using the desktop computer
you're used to at home.
Although your computer
has a lot of technology
that's optimized
for how you use it,
our data center servers use
only the components needed
for lean, high performance.
When multiplied
by the thousands,
we provide you a sweet spot
between performance and cost.
Google Cloud servers are built
using the Google Titan chip
from the time of manufacturing.
Titan helps secure every server
through its entire lifecycle.
It uses Root of Trust
technology, which
cryptographically ensures that
the chip hasn't been tampered
with and significantly reduces
the chance of vulnerabilities.
But what happens if
the machine fails?
Billions of users
depend on our services
being up and running
24/7, so Google
uses a fault-tolerant
design that's
maintainable from
concept to operations.
At the infrastructure
level, this
boils down to constant
monitoring of every hardware
component, electrical,
and mechanical system
for configuration, activity,
environmental, and error data.
We use machine learning
and machine failure
diagnostic tools to
suggest corrective actions.
And because we're constantly
upgrading and reconfiguring
our infrastructure, our
hardware operations teams
do deployments, maintenance,
upgrades, and repairs
of all hardware 24/7.
This all comes with
the key responsibility
of protecting and securing our
data centers for every user
and Google Cloud customer.
More on that next time on
"Discovering Data Centers."
[MUSIC PLAYING]